ciao ragazzi volevo ringraziarvi di
cuore per questo traguardo incredibile
che sono 4 milioni di iscritti è un
traguardo veramente assurdo io non so
come anche come spiegarlo e volevo dirvi
per chi non lo sapesse che per questi 4
milioni di iscritti
ho preparato quattro speciali questo
video che state per vedere che un
momenti epici normale delle scene più
belle che sono successe nell'ultimo
periodo vi faccio vedere una cosa che in
teoria non dovevo farvi vedere ma lo
faccio lo stesso perché sono acam voi
conoscete il logo fa dj no e sempre
stato così dal mondo aperto il canale il
logo da oggi cambierà completamente
quindi il logo fa vj che conoscete tutti
da anni non sarà più quello ma cambierà
in questo
però mi piace perché a me piace ciò che
hanno messo una vita a farlo quindi
fatelo piacere bella i ragazzi spero che
vi piaccia buona visione
sbaglio lo avete visto tante volte
correva la tua madre
puoi diventare invisibile per un
capriccio ogni volta che tu fai che lo
faito che si restringe di un millimetro
tranquilla anzi che tanto possiamo
respingerli con dove sarà sempre
abbastanza
inizia per b finisce con l'h anno vico
ai qua no paper che regga dai cat roja
ciò che trovava in giro per casa a nudo
così c'è un motivo a questa cosa so
quanti anni hai averi volte 2017 30 43
anni 44 protocollato già fatti 71 73
c'è il doppio dei miei anni va bene noi
che vivete allora marga d'accusa natale
ghana targa di [ __ ] ma no all ages
la valanga vediamola el'altro ma questo
ancora vivo adesso no è la prima tappa
su un blog al mare tra l'altro
beh mica come non mi è venuta questa
idea prima la madonna quanto salta però
troppo cazzo
vedo che non sia proprio il massimo per
il tuo fisico quello che sta succedendo
adesso porca vacca non saremo per niente
che sfiga schifosa laida ok ok ok
stanotte ci sono dove l'ultimo
checkpoint tutte una mia sorella notaio
o da tempo fa vj e il chiaro affitto
come madonna mia che grande essi stessi
potenziate anche illusi a questo caso
posso creare il gioco dell'anno
[Musica]
puttanate casa collins locali ma donovan
e vabbè magari si sono attivati i tasti
fermare il di e guido ma punta a [ __ ]
ci terrei a dire che se fossi veramente
io questa persona è data la censura in
questo momento sarebbe così quindi non
siate timidi signore non si è definito
come si chiama la mamma di famiglia e
quasi azzecchi ci sono dei problemi
perché non puoi sapere il nome di
laura ci sono i pro die die
ma perché noi italiani siamo sempre al
top sulle mani se hai visto hai visto lo
alzato lo alzate ho fatto così ho fatto
così fuori intelligente è nemica amica
stefan vito un ragazzo stupida ciao
iscritti mai fregato
nello speciale di quanti iscritti ha
fatto ladro mylife razza che rai mai ma
se la zecchi sera sul palco in mutande
ma io direi 45 milioni
facciamo stasera sul palco in mutande
a
tra le ragazze la facciamo così
disattiviamo quello schifo andrò a
vedere se riusciamo a tornare giù in
teoria c'è questa scala spero funzioni
che cazzo sei sopra secondo me la scala
non funziona però va bene salve e quella
porta non si apre che non posso
chiuderla merda perfetto
[Musica]
avete mai visto un finale più poetico di
questo devo che mi ha stuprata
non posso essere così demente rega ti
prego dammi 9 donna del mio nome
baguette assieme a post
[Musica]
e possibile prendere questo pulsante ha
mai vostro cane gatto morirà subito sì
perché no nun ciavemo bella negli ultimi
anni è molto anche perché però
schiacciato scusa come a settembre
mostro ha messo settembre ragazzi spero
che o video vi sia piaciuto madonna
centravanti in bolle si sono ancora
antenna a perché tu non hai ancora visto
casa mia a fondo maggio fagioli zio mi
raccomando 3 quando esplode avuto
succede comunque spessissimo un agente
puzza in atto non tutti che non voglio
vedere capisco perché ok
perché ora ci sono quando hai voglia poi
vai vai vai ma è velocissimo e pensavo
torre s pian piano io prenderò più o
meno il ritmo è la cosa che pian piano
nel senso nevrosi martile prego ti prego
ti prego pietro pietro
[Musica]
perché lo rendono un perché
sì
un anno e mezzo per questa chiacchierata
un anno siamo arrivati a questo punto
dove cazzo andato alla mia chiave
[Musica]
maietta diventi super intelligente
facciamoci al 100 inserito è giulia
sì ci ho fatto non ci posso credere ma
[ __ ] basta basta basta basta basta
basta basta basta
[Musica]